Groundhog Day Super Bowl it really is
vii Super Bowl for the Patriots in this
new regime I always have to clarify that
now because it's actually didn't watch
the page it's actually patriot
knucklehead fans who come out and say oh
we're 985 bears and when we lost the
Packers I'm talking about the regime I'm
talking in Belichick Brady this
particular regime being the greatest
sports dynasty of all time it was a
blowout paid rs.1 easy Falcons won easy
so interesting game for the Super Bowl I
listen I watch the game there's a
methodical is never in doubt I don't
think there's any way the Patriots lose
the Falcons I close my eyes try to
imagine it I try to think how can the
Falcons beat the pages I don't think
there is a chance I don't know what's
gonna happen the Falcons if they weren't
this is gonna sound weird
if the Falcons weren't the Falcons yeah
like you said that's the biggest problem
the biggest problem of this team is that
they're the Atlanta Falcons agreed so
having said that they're a good team and
it almost in a weird way reminds me of
the Arizona Cardinals who lost to the
Steelers and it's the Steelers our
friends are not gonna beat ya Larry
Johnson Larry Fitzgerald had a huge game
and they were very good and maybe better
I don't know what happens here but I
know the Patriots are gonna win and I'm
gonna get my revenge on Roger Goodell
with the crowd of Patriot fans which to
be honest the more I think about I don't
know how I'm not part of that vendetta
that mob scene of people trying to just
assassinate Roger Goodell I mean what
can you say it both games spunk yeah
enjoyable to watch and this whole season
seems like a foregone conclusion for the
patrons yeah why every year is I mean
especially as a patriot ATAR it's every
year I just assume it's going to happen
and when it doesn't that's the surprise
that's where it's at I agree with the
name of the Atlanta Falcons it's kind of
like the Tampa Bay Rays
you just can't ever and the worst one
backs of won a World Series but you're
still like they're not denied
that's the Falcons though they are a
very exciting team that offense is like
a video game I know you're not worried
at all Dave I know you're gonna say any
time I try to say well you know this
team actually has some talent they do
have talent their defenses come on real
I mean they showed out Aaron Rodgers in
the first half mmm-hmm that was legit
you
don't just do that like by accident and
Matt Ryan is playing out of his mind
Julio Jones who you're Jones gonna be
the best player on the field in my mind
yeah but you know it's like better than
Tom Brady at their current states yes
the problem though is that the Patriots
we just have someone step up and play
like Julio Jones like Chris
alright just like it doesn't matter who
the stars are the Patriots always just
do it anyway great I just I'm
just gonna do a call back here to what
you just I told Brady's playing as well
as he's ever played the best player of
all time Oh Jones is making plays and
running like a lot like the plays he
makes I don't know how anyone could ever
guard him I'm just saying I mean that's
that's one man's opinion I know you're
obviously on patriot like mode right now
I feel like the last week it was Aaron
Rodgers versus Tom Brady and then like
Rogers gets shuts out and we just forget
we had that conversation Julio Jones
great player but Brady is playing as
well as he's ever played it's a square
volt any times I'm Brady steps on the
football field he's the most influential
player in that game no matter who's
facing out because yeah I miss probably
fair I just die Julio Jones but I
haven't seen this stuff Julio Jones
doing easily I also like to say
radio it's probably because Brady's been
doing it for so long and it's the same
Brady effort Julio Jones is doing
I'm like holy how's this I agree
it's great player but there's also for
actually doing X's and O's which is I
know people I go I'm not really thinking
about that I'm thinking about just I'm
so convinced the Patriots gonna win this
game I can't imagine a scenario they
don't because it's the Atlanta Falcons
but X's and O's wise we will take Julio
Jones out of the game like the Patriots
take your best offensive player and
somebody else is gonna have to beat the
Patriots yeah the Falcons have all their
guys they have that a lot of I mean some
of these guys Coleman is like he's
another guy who's been making plays that
you're like holy this guy's a video
quick shout out to the Stewie who pulled
the fire alarm on the Steelers and then
we got an email that they were talking
about all day we got the police like
report of him getting arrested ah that
quote I'm dumb I'm drunk and I'm a fan
and I love it and to be honest I think
that's fair game
I think pulling fire alarms when you on
the road we did in the Super Bowl we
guarded the Patriots fire alarmist
because it got pulled twice if you don't
want your fire alarms pulled get
home-field advantage and by the way
don't let people find
know where you're staying so shout out
to that guy tip of the cap you did get
arrested I don't know what's gonna
happen but they should send him to the
Super Bowl so good job by him I don't
know if you guys feel that way or not
but I want to give him sign since they
sent us the police report
moving on away from the Super Bowl and
there'll be a lot of Patriot talk a lot
by the way the pelicans have no fans I
did this on the Sirius show even the
fans were like any Falcons fans call in
they didn't even call we had the the
number one like Falcon Atlanta radio
show us brought Brian Finneran we caught
him caught he was so boring it's like
this is they could even get excited if I
was saying these things that people are
saying Atlanta I'm like it's the worst
city no fans they only have strip clubs
it's a franchise nobody cares about yeah
you may be right
it's just I mean that's what we're doing